breaking news a black man babysitting
two white kids had the cops called on
him and was questioned by the police
you're probably waiting for the rest of
the story like oh well what did this guy
do that was suspicious or had the
children been reported missing or was
the black man seen beating the white
kids in public there's no more story
like I've told you the whole story a
black guy was babysitting two white kids
and the police were called by a a white
woman in Georgia who called and said
there's a black man with two white kids
come talk to the black guy apparently is
what she said she saw them outside of a
Walmart in Cobb County the man's name is
Corey Lewis he's the black babysitter
who was asked by the woman to speak to
the children the guy said what most
parents or caretakers or guardians would
say if a random stranger comes up to you
in a parking lot and says I want to talk
to these kids you're with he said no and
you can't talk to these kids so she
called the cops
followed the guy in her vehicle as he
left the Walmart parking lot police
officer shows up talks to the guy talks
to the kids calls their parents and the
parents say yeah the black guys our
friend and he's babysitting our kids the
mother is named Dana mango I kind of
liked that last name maybe it's because
I love mango so much but I like that
last name mango you could be David mango
I I actually David mango show hasn't as
a nice ring to it Dana mango said to
local news station WGCL that the police
officer straight-up told her the black
guy was questioned because we received a
call about a black man driving around
two white kids that was the basis for
the call and there's an article in
people about this the mom said I asked
the police officer are you telling me
that because there's an african-american
male driving my two white kids he was
stopped and questioned by police and the
officers said I'm sorry ma'am that's
exactly what I'm saying
we have video
take a look I said why my yeah I got I
got I got I'm baby I got two kids on
babysitting we ate a subway at Walmart
when you got some guys she pull it up
talking about some other kids okay why
wouldn't they be okay
no one's yelling I was screaming that
was trying to run away she left came
back and said ask to see the little girl
so she can ask her if she's does she
know who I am
yep all right and then I went over to
get some gas at Murphy's she came back
back that's crazy
I mean why so that what you heard at the
end first you heard a black guy just
explaining why it's not a concern of law
enforcement that a black man is with two
white kids right that was that's the
context that's what this guy was
explaining uh-uh
they're with me they know me nothing's
going on they're not screaming they're
not crying
at the end what you hear is the officer
insisting on talking to the kids and
Corey Lewis says that's crazy nothing's
going on here and the cop insists on
talking to the kids we're not gonna even
though the video is out there I don't
want to put the kids in the video so
we're gonna we're gonna skip past that
the officer in the interim time that
we're skipping over has spoken to the
kids which I don't want to include and
then this is sort of how the thing wraps
up just the last few seconds of this
video I'm letting the work now I'm less
yeah now I'm letting the world know like
what's really going on it's 2018 I can't
without being the guy was babysitting
while black babysitting while black is
what was going on here
I suppose the cop did an okay job here
he is responding to a call after all so
he has to interview some people my
biggest takeaway though was the cop
seemed very
unenthused by the whole thing like maybe
you should find another another
profession because he just didn't seem
very into it I want to think about
another element of this how would the
woman who called the police have reacted
if a random person came up to her at
wall
and demanded to speak to her kids as if
that's a normal thing to do if random
strangers come up to most parents and
totally out of context say I'd like to
speak to your children most parents
would say no this is just racism it's
racial prejudice we don't need to do an
overly complex analysis of what's going
on here and in fact if I was the
babysitter
I would have called the police he's
being confronted by a stranger in a
public place
he is the at this point he's in charge
of these kids he's the Guardian for
these kids stranger is confronting him
and demanding to speak to those children
he doesn't know who she is and then she
follows him home in a vehicle which is
intimidate Ori without question I
actually have a friend who's black here
in Massachusetts and his wife is white
and they have two kids and one of the
kids looks much more Caucasian whatever
whatever we you know imagine what
interpret that however you want then the
other
he's never been confronted by anybody
but he has told me stories of perceiving
tension and sort of strange looks when
he's with just like the more Caucasian
looking kid without the wife and that's
Massachusetts so imagine what it's like
in places like Georgia and Mississippi
and other parts of the country yeah it's
really unfortunate and you'd have to
imagine that this woman isn't calling
the cops anytime she sees kids with
parents oh you know like if it's white
kids with white parents she's not
calling the cops
that was black kids with black parents
she's not calling the kyai assume this
is the only scenario right if she saw I
don't know a white parent a white adult
with two asian kids is she calling the
cops I don't think so no I don't think
she is send me your thoughts about the
story make sure that you're following
the David Pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show we have a great
behind-the-scenes picture that we're
gonna be posting of what the setup
around me looks like and just kind of
like a zoomed out you know it's kind of
a shot where you don't see what's going
on around me but we have actually a
picture we're going to be posting where
you will see it so follow the show on
instagram at david pakman show follow me
on instagram at david dot Pakman
yesterday I was actually interviewed for
a very interesting documentary film
about the current
ministration and I posted some
behind-the-scenes pictures of that a
very very compelling stuff happening on
Instagram is the point we'll take a
quick break back after this with Nathan
J Robinson very very interesting today's
program brought to you in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a great
service that i use all the time what
they do is they take thousands of the
most popular non-fiction books including
the newest bestsellers they condense
them into 15-minute audiobooks that you
can listen to and you still get the most
crucial information and insights from
each book and I've listened to a ton of
books on blink Asst I recently checked
out soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we
do have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber
which I listened to on blinka they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you'd like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be li NK
is t.com /p a que mas